well I think that what's happening now
is the transformational moments here in
American culture I think the fact that
the majority of Americans now support
marijuana legalization is a huge win for
civilization for mankind I mean for
American society it's like not just for
the sort of limitless medicinal
potential that cannabis has you know
cannabinoids have been shown that so
even like shrink tumors I mean it's it's
unbelievably therapeutically active
substance but also for the simple issue
of cognitive liberty right sort of a
country that it's founded on the
principles of free thought and the idea
the idea that everybody should be able
to think what they want to think and do
what they want to do as long as they're
not hurting anybody else and this is you
know nowhere more exemplified than in
the right to choose a marijuana joint
over a martini if that's what floats
your boats
also marijuana consciousness as rich
Doyle writes is extraordinarily
sensitive to the initial rhetorical
conditions
you know Leary's ubiquitous set and
setting to the point that there is no
drug by itself there is the context in
which the drug is taken and so when you
change the cultural context in which
people are able to have marijuana you
change the particular flavor of
marijuana consciousness you start
eliminating the association with
criminality and the paranoia and the
fear of getting caught and instead you
create a canvas where people can smoke a
joint before going to a boutique movie
theater to a very increased cinematic
immersion or you can create spaces where
people can maybe vaporize some cannabis
before going in and listening to a
symphony orchestra or maybe they can go
on this beautiful you know sort of
dieded marijuana hikes where where the
the set and setting would be curated for
a particular marijuana flavor I mean
it's it's almost like the notion of then
the notion being that that intention you
know you change the intention you change
the stage and that intention could
actually transform the subjective
experience that people have when they
participate in the use of of cannabis
you know it's just very exciting because
I think that we're gonna see new forms
of entertainment new forms of sort of
new cultural spaces
people to partake in what they've been
doing for hundreds of thousands of years
which is altering our consciousness
whether it's through external
technologies or internal technologies I
mean mindfulness meditation rave
concerts you know Burning Man theater
these are all technologies techniques
rhetorical technologies that capture and
manage attention and are able to elicit
transformational interpersonal
experiences only when we are immersed in
some capacity as Diana Slattery says can
you mediate attention and can you can
you actually have transformational
educational interpersonal experiences
that people pay money for that they're
like here's $20 you know put me in that
IMAX movie theater and take me through
through a black hole let me experience
interstellar you know where the outer
journey becomes a metaphor for the inner
journey the external outer space
interstellar becomes a metaphysical
head-trip I mean we pay money to be
taken out of ourselves we pay money to
dissolve boundaries we pay money to
experience inter subjective life worlds
and anything that helps us get there as
long as it's not hurting anybody else
it's cool man it's cool and so I mean
I'm interested I'm interested in what's
going to come out of that you know what
what this what this boutique high-end
marijuana culture is going to create the
marijuana equivalent of the high-end
wine bar or the really really trendy
Scotch bar where everything from the
lighting to the music to the cups in
which people drink the alcohol is
created to create a certain mood what's
gonna be the marijuana equivalent of
that the sort of highbrow experience for
aesthetically minded types it's a great
book by David linson where he talks
about the marijuana consciousness as one
which creates this dialectical pattern
of reconcilable estrangement so the
first thing that happens and again
reconcilable estrangement with the world
of perception so the first thing that
happens is there's an Italian of
experience by distancing you from the
set of stimuli it's why you know why a
sort of aspect might smoke a joint
before going to the Guggenheim he's
going there to experience first an
alienation from the world of ordinary
perception so things become novel new
and interesting and strange and then
there's a reconciliation with that
estrangement so
the world is italicized the world is
seen as if for the first time and then
right afterwards there's a witnessing of
that transformation and a reconciliation
with the world of objects so that the
thing that is seen as if for the first
time can be regarded can be revered we
call this sort of sacred consciousness
archetypical consciousness you know so
that something like an ordinary scoop of
ice-cream represents the idea of
ice-cream you know a piece of art of
sculpture standing you know standing in
a museum hallway becomes becomes a sort
of archetypical figure of man trying to
make a statement you know using form and
function you know it's just I just think
that what what it does to consciousness
is very useful because it provides a
change in perspective similar to when
astronauts go to space and have a change
in perspective what they call the the
orbital orbital overview effect that
transforms the consciousness of the
astronauts because they're able to see
reality in this case Earth from a
different perspective that creates an
ontological transformation blasting new
tunnels between the mind and the other
so - in the world of everyday life
people will be able to alter their
consciousness legally in a safe space
and have that change in perspective that
results hopefully in some kind of
transformation heightened appreciation
increased compassion increased
well-being and increased creativity it
reminds me a bit of that Stanford study
on the subject of awe where they
described aw as an experience of such
perceptual expansion or such perceptual
vastness that you have to reconfigure
your mental maps of the world to
assimilate the experience so maybe the
first time you saw the Grand Canyon the
first time you saw the IMAX film of the
Hubble Space Telescope and it turns out
that ah once it passes leaves us with
all these increased feelings of bliss
well-being creativity compassion
kindness right and so if we're able to
mediate an assist eliciting those
sensations of awe in this case by
legalizing marijuana in safe context
then why shouldn't we do that well
that's that's what kind of excites me
you know just just the notion that there
are new modalities of consciousness that
we will be able to safely
war and inhabit